great filmmaking isn't just a
measurement of the money a movie can
earn at the box office
however when a film truly deserves the
boom it's frustrating to watch it crash
instead
marvel's black widow is more than worthy
of a financial win
it has everything non-stop action a
compelling backstory female characters
who support rather than turn on each
other
and strong heroines who can beat the
crap out of their enemies while still
expressing human emotions
there's no romantic subplot to derail
the story nor the typical late scene
where a male character jumps in to make
the save
the only things lacking are a couple of
cliched elements we are used to seeing
in most action movies
that's why it's so disheartening to see
the faltering earnings for black widow
it's easy to cast blame when a movie
offers low budget special effects lame
storytelling and weak acting
but that's certainly not the case here
so who's fault is it that this film
isn't getting its due at the box office
anyone who's watched the film won't be
surprised to hear black widow was made
on an impressive 200 million dollar
budget
that investment was expected to pay off
at the box office and when opening
weekend brought in 80 million dollars a
new record was set
according to variety sounds great right
except that wasn't as much as the
national association
of theater owners hoped for on opening
weekend the organization believes the
take could have been more like 92 to 100
million
or more things only got worse when the
movie made a mere 26 million dollars
during its second weekend in theaters
that's a massive 69 drop without much
explanation
and when something goes wrong to the
tune of tens of millions of dollars you
can bet people are going to look into
the situation
were fans really over black widow only a
week out it seemed an unlikely
scenario especially considering people's
limited entertainment options during the
pandemic era
and the collective excitement about
theater's reopening spoiler alert
all of this speculation contains several
clues to the truth about what happened
to black widow at the box office
we've all witnessed how kobe's
destructive reach has gone far beyond
human health to wreak havoc
on social systems and businesses that
includes theaters forced to close when
communities locked down to prevent the
diseases spread
it's good news that theaters are back
open now but everything's relative these
days that 80 million
record black widows said on opening
weekend it's more specific than it
sounds
according to variety it's a covid era
record before the pandemic theaters had
an edge when showing new releases
they were the only option for viewers
who wanted to see a movie during its
first
75 days out after that the film could be
released to streaming services giving
viewers the option of watching from the
comfort of their own couch
when covet hit streaming services
started offering new releases straight
out of the gate
after all it was the only way to reach
viewers it was a loyalty building move
that served customers desperate for some
distraction
a win-win for everyone except theater
owners who could only hope to recover
upon reopening
yet here we are with black widow proving
recovery isn't so easy
now that it's finally possible to watch
a film in an actual theater
a movie like black widow should kill at
the box office however there's more to
the story that leads to an entirely
different ending
when black widow hit theaters on july 9
disney plus subscribers could also view
it at home
it was a simultaneous release that
harkens back to the beginning of the
pandemic
which despite hopeful reopenings isn't
actually over yet
according to variety disney decided
viewers still needed the option to watch
black widow for the premium price of 30
from home if that felt more comfortable
the end result according to the national
association of theater owners was
financial loss
all around the movie would have done
better at the box office and on disney
plus if the release had been handled
differently
the organization asserted in variety
simultaneous release is a pandemic-era
artifact that should be left to history
with the pandemic itself
they continued calling black widow box
office numbers disappointing and
anomalous if there's any comfort to be
had in this moment
it's in knowing we're not the only ones
who feel let down
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one